alrighty folks so today my producers
have picked a video that they want to
show me i don't know what it is
the only thing i know about it is that
legolas might be in it from lord of the
rings
so i'm up for
let's it this works we've got to tell
them
wait who are these people wait stop that
isn't that orlando bloom and katy perry
oh my god but they're in the future and
um
apparently super ugly there's like 30
years in the future so they got like
super duper ugly they age poorly
boom roasted
[Music]
i just want to note that this is the
first time that orlando bloom has been
on camera for like 10 years right since
like pirates
you are our only hope the america you
know doesn't exist in our future
democracy is dead we have no voice
the regime watches our every move oh
they're against
big government surveillance on the left
now they don't like the big government
the big government controlling every
aspect of your life is something left
very much opposes
in this future or something
okay
voter suppression ran wild all over
america the voting rights bills died in
the senate
hauling places closed we lost our but
why isn't she riding a giant lion
or tiger or whatever isn't that like not
good guys this future doesn't have to be
you have the power to change it save
democracy while you can
call your senator now tell daisy
first of all they have pretty advanced
technology that they can go back in time
so that's kind of awesome
also has orlando bloom become an
american citizen at this point
and what is his immigration status i
actually don't know the answer to that
question it's an honest question
[Music]
um what
is that supposed to creep me out or am i
supposed to be laughing because it's
really funny
so first of all long fall from katy
perry at the dnc
performing roar i'm going to vote for
hillary clinton
to uh being apparently a homeless
refugee from the matrix
not like this and orlando bloom doesn't
look a lot like legolas anymore i mean
it's been a while since he's been an
actual good movie so
i guess this is the best thing he's been
in for like what five six years
something like that
i just have to say the absurdity of
watching very very wealthy hollywood
celebrities who live in the most
prosperous system in the history of
mankind
whine about how their vote is going to
be removed when there is literally no
evidence their vote is going to be
removed
is pretty amazing it's pretty incredible
also this is solid politics
what you really want to do if you're
seeking to attract joe manchin to your
agenda
is to suggest that joe manchin is the
enemy and needs to be defeated
and pressured that is most definitely
going to work also i've noticed that
they are very much
in favor of overthrowing republican
checks and balances today in order to
preserve voting in the future when
voting is happening
now this big brain time i honestly
thought it was an snl sketch at the very
beginning of it and then it turned out
not to be
an snl sketch it was just celebrities
being idiots because celebrities don't
understand anything
is math related to science and final
note on sort of the politics of this
if you are a person who keeps saying
over and over and over that voter
suppression is widespread in the united
states you are undermining democracy if
you want to talk about undermining
faith in democracy keep saying that
voter suppression is a regular aspect of
american life that is a complete
and utter lie it is untrue in every
available iteration and yet these morons
are
again the richest most famous people
living in the united states talking
about how voting is
on the edge and let us lie to you to
scare you into pressuring joe manchin
man the tactical brilliance of this
thing and the and the absolute truth
telling is
beyond comprehension okay
about us who are they we bring together
conservatives progressives and everyone
in between to pass powerful state and
local laws that fix our broken elections
and stop political bribery
our strategy is central to dismantling
the root causes of inequities in our
democracy
and ending political corruption
extremism and gridlock um i
really really doubt that they're
bringing together conservatives
progressives and everyone in between i
think they're bringing together
progressives
leftists and everyone in between ooh
there's an advisory council and
everything okay so who is on the
advisory council
uh a single registered republican
theodore roosevelt iv who's famous
because
he had a great grandfather apparently
uh you've got richard painter who
famously was very very anti-trump
larry lessig who's like a nut he tried
to run for president for a second on the
democratic side of the aisle
it's actually kind of an interesting
board if you joined up for this board
not knowing what it was like you should
probably resign from this board
like there's some people who i actually
kind of like their work on here like
jonathan height and
norm ornstein and then there are a bunch
of people who i think are just terrible
i'm confused why this ad is like
that is a pure democratic party
propaganda yeah that's kind of that's
kind of interesting
oh the cultural board oh this is where
they find all their famous friends
okay so we've got orlando bloom jack
black michael douglas jennifer lawrence
adam mckay who's a far lefty kerry
washington who spoke at the dnc
sia i'm just gonna put it out there she
is great and the reason that she is
great is because
she always wears her hair directly over
her entire face even in her like
publicity photos for serious websites
you've got to have some admiration for
that oh there's a pretty big name group
of people
jj abrams that sort of explains why this
video is
like very derivative and repetitive
and also not super coherent and
also why there was random lens flare
it's only a movie
alrighty so that was a nice piece of
propaganda with
celebrities in it how exciting our
politics are so high brow
i'll see you later